olá pessoal de 20 e hoje vou ensinar
como fazer um ar-condicionado cruzeiro
que tentava ligar o computador via usb
estou de férias em portugal faz bastante
calor cá então de fazer algo que vai ser
muito útil nos próximos dias
para isso o senar de basicamente uma
caixa tiver ouvir e de um ventilador aí
comprei duas coisas por mais ou menos
cinco euros mas vocês provavelmente vão
ter uma caixa tiveram êxito em casa e se
vocês também não quiserem comprar a
ventoinha podem sempre usar um curto
computador que vai salvar um pois um
cabo do carregador do telemóvel e juntar
ao curto e pronto vai funcionar na mesma
região que estão a marcar no centro da
tampa e vou cortar não alinhamos
ligeiramente mais para dentro deixando
assim uma borda
um dia depois posso pular aquela parte
usei para marcar por cola na borda e
clara para porque não têm vento ine
essa parte dentro vai ajudar o porteiro
ventoinha do contato com o gelo para
finalizar o paparazzo por cola aqui e
encaixar a ventoinha por cima
agora vocês têm que ceder quanto as
aberturas quer erro fazer quatro
cobertores
vou colocar duas aberturas um lado e
duas no outro pra contar e recomendo que
vocês usei uma faca de cozinha que é
muito mais fácil uma vez que a caixa é
mais grossa
depois é só por lá dentro o que você
usaram para o vídeo podem fixar ou então
não mais documentos
e agora vocês podem pôr gelo em cubo
chamas e acho que fica mais práticas e
em garrafas de xampu algumas garrafas
com água no congelador quando quiserem
usar é só usar uma garrafa foi na caixa
é ligar via usb e pronto já está pronto
a usar a isso em solo portenho estado se
vocês quiserem estar o canal está um
wiki e se inscrevam caso não seja um kit
é isso que tal e amanhã